トーキョ
こんにちはパドルしそうですもう今3月の後半になりました
皆さん新生活始まっていると思いますたぶん引越しってる人もいるし
学校卒業して他の学校に行ったりお仕事にお仕事始めたりする人もいると思うんです
けども私のこの
はずがみゅーずめんとパークにも
新しい人だ
やって来ませんそしてなんとん
祈願は違うんですけども2人しばらく僕の家に一緒にすることになります
1人目はこちらの方デー
[音楽]
白1
あの子の患者放つですと言うけどたなってはもうなってはね返せずに済むでしょ
えっ
されますけど
ていただろう
線チャンネルのバレますよ
ベス増加するんだよ癖がそう夏春からなんか知らないんですけどすごくにするみたいだ
ねで
いいがもう決まっているという
決まってるけど入るまでまだちょっと日があるんで
その後はこのうちにちょっと進んでいくというわけなので
まず払ってちょっと動画で手伝ってもらったり色々出る事が多いかと思います宜しく車
あぁそう
私もう一人の
の固そう実はですねもう1人
しばらく家に住むことになっておりますが
何度ですねうん
女性ぞて何です
ちょっと女性が来るということですごい部分を緊張してるんですけど
お呼びいたしましょうこんなことですかどうぞ
goo
なあ
がする術づらいウォーズと手羽先んがどうぞですどうかねというが何しにけどえっと
もうすぐもう数です後に大学院の修了式っていう間卒業式が
ねそれまでもうこっちの家を引き払っちゃってるので
ここで居候なるほどなるほどいやそんなもいないからなぁ
マサキはもうほんと最後かもしれないで評価取る早々とたぶんこれがもう
ちょっといるときとかいや本当に私は多分もう
静岡に来る最後の機会かもしれないんで
ずっとこの数日間たんか動画一緒に撮れればいいなと思っているところでございます
つま先大治
そモスチョン数字つで承諾して帰っちゃって i
ただっちはもって版いける下手増加
そう
残ってないしますか
バルーン製品じゃねぇ
車2台じゃないですか気づいてね結成家で静岡静岡よ
なんか仕事に静岡に行ってるみたいなんだよすごいな価値と一緒にお手伝いとかが出
たりすると思います
この動画なんだろうというわけで2人がそばでに言えるんで何卒よろしくお願いしまし
たございました
[音楽]
me
car
あっはぁ